now the El Nino weather pattern has
returned earlier than usual and make of
our already warming World an extra kick
of natural heat so let's find out a
little bit more about it El Nino occurs
when Waters in the Eastern Pacific are
warmer than normal its impacts are
varied and unpredictable fueling
tropical Cyclones in the Pacific drought
in Australia as well as flooding rains
in parts of the Americas as well well
the UK Health Security Agency meanwhile
has issued the first heat Health alert
of the year across six regions in
England that will come into place from 9
A.M today and it will continue until
Monday morning so joining me now Sky
meteorologist Joanna Robinson so a Hot
Weekend ahead Joanna
that's exactly right temperatures are on
the rise we've got that heat and
humidity moving in so we're seeing much
higher temperatures over the weekend we
could see 30 or 31 degrees Celsius on
Saturday and Sunday so temperatures are
rising and like you said you there is
that heat Health alert that is in place
across England it's an alert that only
covers England and it's basically
designed to warn Health and Social Care
Professionals about high temp a period
of high temperatures so the temperatures
are rising but along with that we're
going to see increased humidity and we
will see some thunderstorms developing
too so there is a thunderstorm warning
across parts of Wales and Central and
Southern England for Saturday valued
from 2 till 9 pm on Saturday so we could
see some torrential rain hail and those
thunderstorms through the afternoon and
evening as well and there will be a risk
on Sundays Monday as well so do be
prepared that there may be further
warnings issued over the coming days but
it's the heat as well in some parts of
Eastern England where we've had really
cool conditions with that loud lingering
we will see temperatures Rising so it
will be a big change for some Eastern
parts of the country as well so
temperatures are on the rise and
we will have a look at the details now
across the whole country
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
you go the weather sponsored by Qatar
Airways
very warm humid air and some heavy
thundery showers will move in for the
weekend it's mostly dry out there now
with early Cloud thinning and breaking
that's what it's doing here at the
moment but the far Southwest has a few
blustery showers the cloud will quickly
clear during the morning to leave plenty
of sunshine but some North Sea coastal
areas will stay dull there'll also be
patchy Cloud over the south of Ireland
and Southwest England bringing further
well scattered showers overall it'll be
warmer than yesterday if windier in
places but cool again where Cloud
lingers near eastern coast the afternoon
will be similar but the shower risk will
extend further north across Ireland and
then Cloud will spread Inland again
tonight but lesser extent than recently